welcome back to the david pakman show
i'm farin cousins from ring of fire i'll
be sitting in for david all of this week
and if by chance you want more from me
you can find me on youtube at
youtube.com
farron balanced and of course
youtube.com
the ring of fire
one of the biggest stories that is still
happening this week is more and more new
information continues to trickle out
every couple hours honestly at this
point is joe manchin
the biggest baddest bad guy
in the country today joe
manchin
and on monday the huffington post
reported
that joe manchin has allegedly according
to two insiders
that huffington post spoke to
manchin has been telling his democratic
colleagues
that one of the main reasons he is
objecting
to extending the child tax credit that
has lifted 30 percent of children in
this country out of poverty
is because if you give poor people money
they're just going to spend it
on drugs
now there's no audio at least not that
i've
seen or has been reported on of joe
manchin saying these things so let's you
know mention that right off the bat
this is coming from two insiders who
spoke to the huffington post they said
this is what mansion has been telling
people behind the scenes
this is his talking point if you give
poor people money
they're gonna spend it on drugs
so
we have to assume at the moment or at
least for the sake of this
segment here
we're going to assume what they're
saying is accurate again without a
recording of this without it written
down joe manchin writing it himself
we can't say for certain that joe
manchin did say this so let's imagine
that he did okay
let's imagine for a moment that joe
manchin used this tired worn out
republican talking point
to trash the extended child tax credit
which again has lifted 30 percent of
children in this country out of poverty
30 percent
this child tax credit that's been going
out for most of this year has
fundamentally changed the lives of
millions of americans
but it has become one of joe manchin's
biggest targets in the build back better
bill
and is it really because he honestly
thinks that
poor people if they get cash in hand
they're just going to buy drugs is that
really what he believes
does he honestly think
that every poor person in this country
everybody living in poverty is just on
drugs
is that
what he thinks the cause of poverty and
suffering is here in the united states
it's only because of drugs
if somebody is living in poverty
that in no way makes them more likely to
do drugs here in the united states
poverty is not a manifestation
that comes from addiction
and it's absolutely
embarrassing
and irresponsible
for anyone left or right
to make that claim
and if this is in fact
how joe manchin feels if he did really
say this
to his democratic colleagues which i
would love
if any one of them would come forward
and say yes mansion told me this let's
confirm it
so if this did happen
i believe at this point the democratic
party would have no choice but to kick
joe manchin out
and i believe that they should i believe
they should kick him off of his
committees
i believe that they should
refuse to give him any funding from the
party
not just based on this statement either
by the way
based on the fact that he is
obstructing the democrats own agenda
you know bernie sanders pointed out last
week in an interview with chris hayes on
msnbc
that mansion and cinema were acting like
republicans
and when you look at what republicans
have done this year nothing but
obstruction
obstruct obstruct obstruct especially in
the senate
but then when you look at mansion and
cinema
obstruct obstruct obstruct
so it is
as if they were acting like republicans
not as if they are
that is what this is joe manchin
understands what buildback better could
do
to residents of west virginia they're
not happy with him by the way the story
has been pouring in ever since his
appearance on fox news on sunday
about west virginia residents unhappy
that joe manchin is standing in the way
of this
but it all comes down at the moment to
that child tax credit
you know last week mansion
was confronted by reporters
asking why do you oppose the child tax
credit
he said it was bs your bs
this isn't true i never said that i
never did that but
i think it was october 21st
is when the news reports came out saying
that joe manchin wants to cut down the
child tax credit wants to put a cap on
it you know if you make over 60 000 a
year you don't get anything at all
so he wanted to lower the cap that was
reported back then he didn't call those
reports bs
so
he's lying
he's lying to us he's lying to his
constituents he's lying
to the country
about what he actually is trying to do
and again if this huffington post report
is accurate
and again we cannot say for certain that
it happened
but if this report is accurate
then he is basing his rationale for
killing
the extended child tax credit
on faulty and fraudulent information
and that is unacceptable considering how
much this bill
would benefit the american public
it's not going to lead to inflation
it's not going to lead to expanded drug
use here in the united states
it would help continue to lift people
out of poverty
it would help people be able to afford
their bills
it would help people have a way a
stepping stone
to creating a better life that is what
this piece of legislation would do build
back better
is literally right there in the name
folks
but joe manchin doesn't think you should
have it
because joe manchin thinks you're going
to go buy drugs
absolutely sickening
that this sitting democratic member of
the united states senate
would result to republican talking
points going all the way back by the way
to ronald reagan
right the welfare queens
the people living high on the government
hog
while the rest of you hard-working folks
are out there working your fingers to
the bone
but they're getting the free government
money not having to do anything
that's what this is this is a
continuation
of the fraudulent welfare queen trope
pushed by republicans in the 80s and of
course ever since then
not to mention the fact
you know just based on statistics
we know that means testing and of course
drug testing
welfare recipients government assistance
recipients
yields very little results in fact from
2011 to
2017 you had multiple states across the
country
enact some kind of drug testing in order
to receive social well welfare programs
one percent
one percent
of the applicants who were tested
tested positive for drugs one
percent
over a six year
period
so that alone kills joe manchin's
talking point
helps kill that age-old republican
talking point too
but apparently that wasn't enough it
didn't stop joe manchin from allegedly
telling his colleagues
that if you give poor people more money
they're just gonna go spend it on drugs
one of our sponsors is kami koto making
elegant high-end beautiful japanese
steel kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from honshu japan
i've been a big fan of japanese kitchen
knives for a long time they have some
great advantages when you look closely
at a kamikoto knife you see the quality
of the iron work they only use japanese
steel every knife comes in a perfect
heavy duty ash wood box makes storage
really easy it looks great in your
kitchen or drawer the balance of the
knives is just amazing i've been using
them for everything every knife comes
with a lifetime guarantee on their
website you can see the complete list of
chefs at michelin star restaurants who
use kamikota and through this
partnership they're doing with us
kamikoto is giving you fifty dollars off
on top of their other special offers
just go to
kamikodo.com
pacman and use the code pacman for fifty
dollars off
the link is down below